es ist der absolute horror der golfstrom
fällt aus und in europa bricht eine
eiszeit an der golfstrom ist ja eine art
warmwasserheizung so nordeuropa und es
gibt viele forschungsteams die immer
wieder eindringlich davor warnen dass
sich der golfstrom abschwächt ja
vielleicht bald sogar komplett zum
erliegen kommt ausgelöst durch den
klimawandel ein hoch spannendes thema
das ihr euch bei whatsapp gewünscht habt
wie an meine nummer kommt erfahrt ihr am
ende des videos also warum ist der
golfstrom so wichtig und droht uns
tatsächlich eine eiszeit falls er
versiegt hat sie willkommen bei pixum
science fiction
der golfstrom eine art klima motor für
europa dieses strömungs system kommt aus
der karibik genau genommen von den
bahamas auf seinem weg erwärmt sich das
wasser auf bis zu 30 grad celsius und
seine wirkung zeigt sich bis zur küste
norwegens den golfstrom kann man sich
vorstellen wie eine riesige umwälzpumpe
denn zum einen fließt nahe an der
oberfläche warmes tropisches wasser über
den atlantik in richtung europa aus dem
nordatlantik strom verdunstet wasser die
salzkonzentration des meeres steigt
zudem kühlt sich der strom ab beide
faktoren führen dazu dass das wasser
dichter und schwerer wird singt in die
tiefsee hinab gelang zurück nach
südwesten bis zum südatlantik und zwar
als kalte tiefenströmungen somit
verbindet der golfstrom vier der fünf
ozeane miteinander forschungsteams
bezeichnen ihn auch als das globale
förderband von meeresströmungen das
absinken des wassers passiert vor allem
in den nördlichen breiten der labrador
und der grönlandsee 17 millionen
kubikmeter wasser pro sekunde stürzt in
eine tiefe von bis zu 4000 metern der
größte wasserfall der welt und zwar
zwischen grönland und spitzbergen
tatsächlich 15 mal so viel wasser wie
alle flüsse der welt zusammen wow
durch dieses absinken des wassers
entsteht ein sog und eben der zieht den
golfstrom richtung europa im großen und
ganzen haben wir es in mittel und
nordeuropa dem golfstrom zu verdanken
dass hier vor allem im winter eher
mildere temperaturen herrschen es gibt
schätzungen nach denen es ohne ihn in
nord- und nordwesteuropa im durchschnitt
bis zu zehn grad kälter wäre dann sähe
die landschaft eher so aus wie in kanada
karg und eis bedeckt statt grüner wiesen
und wälder die mündung der elbe
beispielsweise wäre wohl wie die hudson
bay monatelang vereist die entscheidende
frage lautet inwieweit beeinflusst der
klimawandel den golfstrom und besteht
die gefahr dass er komplett abreißt
genau dieser frage den forschungsteams
seit den 80er jahren nach denn ihr könnt
euch vorstellen
die antwort darauf ist vielleicht
entscheidend für das leben auf der erde
es gibt viele verschiedene
modellrechnungen aber eines ist ganz
sicher der klimawandel hat auswirkungen
auf den golfstrom diskutiert wird nur
noch wie fatal die folgen wohl sein
werden in früheren analysen könnte sich
der strom um höchstens 20 prozent
abschwächen
selbst wenn sich die
kohlendioxid-konzentration gegenüber der
vorindustriellen zeit verdoppeln würde
die sogenannte atlantik mehr die nova
turning the collection ist demnach
ziemlich stabil so die annahme
andere aktuelle studien dagegen
behaupten das gegenteil
demnach könnten die riesigen strömungen
sogar komplett abreißen wenn sich der
co2 gehalt verdoppelt es sind mehrere
faktoren des klimawandels die den
golfstrom schwächen und lahmlegen
könnten zum einen erwärmt die steigende
globale temperatur das wasser
dieses wird leichter das strömungs
system verliert an antrieb und weniger
warmes wasser gelangt nach nordeuropa
auch das abschmelzen der pole und des
grönlandeises lässt das wasser im
endeffekt leichter werden denn dadurch
nimmt der salzgehalt des meerwassers ab
eine weitere rolle spielt das auftauen
der permafrostböden wodurch sibirischen
flüsse mehr süßwasser in die nördlichen
meere spielen im vergleich zur
eisschmelze wohl aber nur ein kleiner
faktor dieses wissen führt dazu dass
klima forschungsteams den golfstrom sehr
genau im blick haben fest steht er hat
sich in den letzten 100 jahren um zirka
1,2 grad erwärmt der atlantik um 0,5 das
zeigen daten und modellsimulationen von
1900 bis 2008 doch es gibt auch einige
experten und expertinnen die dem
golfstrom längst nicht eine so
bedeutende rolle zuschreiben
sie halten den einfluss des golfstroms
für überschätzt deutschland würde sich
bei einem kompletten zusammenbruch um
durchschnittlich ein bis zwei grad
abkühlen und weiter selbst wenn der
golfstrom im schlimmsten fall komplett
zum erliegen käme würden wir demnach
wohl um sibirische winter drum
herumkommen denn die klimaerwärmung
würde diesen effekt wieder ausgleichen
dennoch in island und skandinavien hätte
ein lahmgelegte golfstrom weitaus
größere folgen die eisdecke würde
anwachsen die temperaturen im winter um
bis zu sieben grad absinken
dies würde zum einen die fischerei und
damit auch die wirtschaft ja ziemlich
stark beeinträchtigen zum anderen würde
auch das regionale klima in vielen
teilen der welt beeinflusst
beispielsweise im mittel und südamerika
da sich der
gürtel über dem tropischen atlantik in
richtung süden verschieben würde
aber auch an den amerikanischen
ostküsten würde der meeresspiegel
steigen hat er ja auch schon begonnen
genauso wie die anzahl der harry kennt
so oder so scheinen die veränderung des
golfstroms erhebliche folgen zu haben
welche genau das werden wir wohl erst in
der zukunft erfahren und wenn er als
erstes neues zum thema golfstrom und zu
den klimaänderungen dadurch erfahren
wollt und zu allen anderen themen dann
endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp
da müsst ihr einfach nur hier
draufklicken dann erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
dadurch mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum
passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der genau glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken klimawandel weltweites
wetterchaos hat begonnen ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran